Every one of us should have at least
some sort of basic training
so if a disaster happened you'd know the basics.
So it won't be your first time when it actually happens.
At UCLA, due to our geographic location, we face a multitude
of hazards from earthquakes to fires,
floods, active shooter situations.
CERT stands for Community Emergency Response Team.
We train people right here on campus at UCLA
to be prepared for large-scale disasters.
I thought it was very important to have a strong presence at UCLA.
Every day I believe there's 90,000 people that come onto campus
and in an event that something does happen it is imperative that we are prepared
CERT Training consists of eight different modules
taught in class.
We teach all kinds of hands-on skills that goes from
basic disaster preparedness, having a kit,
creating a plan to knowing how do you use a fire extinguisher.
At the very end we also have a live action drill with live victims.
During the drill, we were
able to practice our concept all the
theory that we learn in class.
For our drills we use various campus locations
to make it as realistic as possible we
also always invite people to play live victims.
With the blood, the makeup artist
that came in and it was pretty gross
everyone should take part in CERT
because these are lifelong skills that
you're going to learn.
My goal with the CERT Club is to give it more of a
presence on campus where more students are involved. So that way they're more
prepared in emergency situations so that
the campus can be safer and better
prepared for disasters.
If you're a staff, student or faculty here at UCLA
and would like to register for one of our classes
go visit our website: OEM.ucla.edu.
And under trainings you will find our
CERT program where you can RSVP.